mark so let's start with the dual camera
system how big of an upgrade is this
well this is a significant upgrade and
to be clear we are hearing that this
dual camera system will be exclusive to
the bigger iPhone model the one with the
5.5 inch screen the call it the plus
model and with this dual camera system
allows Apple to do is add a lot of
functionality like better low-light
photography so if you take pictures at
night better pictures in dark rooms it
allows for deeper zoom so when you zoom
into the picture it won't become as
blurred as it might on a current or past
iPhone lots of enhancements to the
coloring and the photo editing so it's a
very significant upgrade for the camera
and how does this fit into apples
redesign cycle right so Apple normally
redesigns the iphone pretty much
completely every two years or so so we
saw the big iphone 4 upgrade after the
iphone 3g and 3gs we saw the iphone 5
and the iphone 6 for this new phone
coming this year which a lot of people
have called the iphone 7 it's going to
be retaining the same design as the
iphone 6 from 2014 so this is going to
be the first time where Apple's using
the same design for three years in a row
so that's a pretty significant change
for the company and its to be seen if
this is the beginning of a new pattern
so it does sound honestly mark like you
know what's the point in buying this
particular one just wait for the next
cycle right I feel like a lot of people
are going to say the same thing if
they're coming from an iphone 6s but I
think if you're coming from an iphone 6
or earlier it's a pretty substantial
upgrade because if you think about it if
you're coming from an iphone 6 you're
pretty much getting everything of the
iphone 6s brought in addition to
everything that this new model is going
to bring it's also going to be a big
upgrade for people coming to the iphone
for the first time it'll be the latest
and greatest in the holiday season so
I'm sure it'll still be successful when
is Apple going to change its no
montessori why the 6s and and now
whatever this is and then next year
maybe it'll be the seven we wouldn't it
be a lot
easier and almost maybe more enticing if
they had a different naming mechanism I
agree and there's been a lot of talk and
indicators that Apple is going to maybe
even drop the numbers all together
they've done that for the iPads in
recent years they've never done it for
the Mac or the ipods so perhaps this
will be the beginning of that we will
see a lot of times they like to do the
numbers because it helps case makers
sell cases it helps marketing wise but I
agree with you it's time for a sea
change on the numbers it's getting a
little bit updated in my opinion as well
amok will these new modules be critical
to the holiday season absolutely apples
you know cash cow is the iphone and
their biggest quarter traditionally is
the q1 holiday quarter so this is going
to be a big part of that because if the
iphone is Apple's biggest part of its
revenues and profits it's going to be a
big part of the q1 as well it also touch
a bit on q4 so this new phone will
likely as it has in the past touch about
the first week or two of q4 so we'll
start seeing the results in just a few
months on this phone mark tell us a
little bit restless 10 sorry Nero I was
going to ask the same question Bonnie go
ahead my sure yes iOS 10 is a
significant software update for the
iphone it brings a lot to widgets it has
a new lock screen where people can more
easily and quickly view text messages
emails frequent contacts calendar
appointments next maps destinations it
brings new versions of Apple maps Apple
music and Apple news they're all
completely redesigned it looks a bit
more like a newspaper or customizable
layout it's simpler there's new
messaging features which are really
going to become popular with a lot of
people used to we chat and Weibo and
twitter and facebook Messenger so
there's a lot of enhancements coming
there that I think people are going to
like